[Musik]
hauptbestandteil ist zum einen unser
Olivenöl das machen wir auch selbst dass
das Olivenöl was es auch eben zum
Verzehr gibt und das in der wirklich
ganz viele Antioxidantien drin und was
viele nicht wissen Olivenöl ist wirklich
sehr sehr gut zu Haut pflegt die Haut
und hat ganz viele tolle Vitamine
enthalten und vor allem hat Olivenöl
sogar einen Sonnenschutzfaktor muss man
dazu sagen hier habe ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen share Butter dann haben wir
noch weitere ganz tolle Fette die eben
die Haut pflegen mit Feuchtigkeit und
Vitaminen versorgen und dafür sorgen
dass ihr alle schön und lange jung
bleibt wie z.B Kokosöl ich habe eine
Rizinusöl was ich auch persönlich ganz
gerne für Haut und Haare verwende weil
es bei den Haaren zum einen gegen
Haarausfall ist und eben auch das
Haarwachstum verstärkt z.B für
Augenbrauen oder Wimpern ganz gut
geeignet dann haben wir auch eine
Schwarzkümmelöl ich habe hier ein
Johanniskrautöl und das sind wirklich
alles ganz tolle Bestandteile